c'est au cirque de bruno est le cirque
dans les étoiles à aubergenville
qu'antoine poussins vient régulièrement
s'entraîner et répété ses numéros
je commence toujours sur son tapis de
sol changer nage fait une demi heure
trois quarts d'heure des fois une heure
ça dépend et puis ensuite je commence à
les airs
une passion qu'il découvre retard enfant
hyperactif il a toujours été attiré par
le sport
orienté ans et ap plomberie il profite
de la fermeture de l'entreprise où il se
forme pour partir en quête de nouvelles
aventures
c'est en faisant de l'animation qu'ils
découvrent finalement le cirque et ses
disciplines aériennes
je dirais que ma fierté aujourd'hui
c'est d'être allé chercher ça de moi
même j'ai fait différents corps de
métier j'ai voyagé et ça m'a permis de
me construire et d'en être là où j'en
suis aujourd'hui
c'est ma passion tout ça c'est mes
passions réunies ce soit le cirque le
sport la scène la danse le théâtre le
sais moi en fait
donc si je peux inspirer les enfants à
leur donner un peu de belles de belles
images de beaux souvenirs
[Musique]
j'ai un peu de créativité je le fais
transmettre en snack le meilleur de moi
on est quoi aujourd'hui on est non bien
entendu on est quoi ok très bien on va
faire les porter depuis son retour dans
les yvelines
antoine poussins propose des stages de
cirque aux enfants pendant les vacances
scolaires
pendant une semaine les jeunes
neauphle-le-château j'aime développer
leur créativité
après un échauffement permettant de bien
se défouler et des figures les enfants
apprennent à jongler et s'essaye sur le
trapèze à force tu vas y arriver
moi c'est tombé mille fois moins que j'y
arrive
c'est l'esprit l'esprit de cirque et
puis je pense que chaque individu a sa
propre créativité et aussi sa propre
limite ce qui peut lui permettre
justement de pouvoir développer
je veux dire à sa guise de montrer des
choses qui n'ont pas encore été vu et et
ça ce que pour lui-même et pour pouvoir
inspirer les autres
1 2 3 le cirque c'est les prix des
multiples voyages et une années passées
au sein de l'association au mann heat à
marseille où il enseigne son art aux
enfants et se produit en spectacle c'est
tout naturellement à plaisir qu antoine
boussin revient pour créer sa
micro-entreprise
j'ai eu un déclic je me suis dit j'ai
envie de devenir créer quelque chose
fonder quelque chose à partir d'un
endroit et je pense que le seul endroit
qui m'est venu c'était celui ci une
sorte de retour aux sources pour
l'artiste qui commençait sa formation
pour devenir professeur de cirque
il ya tout juste six ans c'est pas un
hasard pourquoi je suis arrivé dans le
cirque
ça c'est drôle que ce soit arrivé à
aussi tard mon enfance particulièrement
je les ai vécus ici et il parle du
château il reflète vraiment l'endroit où
j'ai grandi
le jeune auto-entrepreneur multiples
activités entre l'enseignement et
l'événementiel antoine poussan a fait de
sa passion son métier